russia powering businesses heating homes
plant spokesperson nicola regensberger
says it's a critical supply
this plant is particularly important for
europe she tells me the gas reaches
millions of households through germany
and further into the european gas
network
and all the while it flows in from the
west money heads back the other way
every single day europe pays russia
hundreds of millions of pounds for its
oil and gas in fact since the invasion
began germany alone has paid a total of
nearly seven and a half billion pounds
effectively financing the war in ukraine
everyone agrees that eventually that has
to stop but the question now is how fast
and on whose terms
we do have problems if the energy will
be cut off or would be cut off and we
are dead we can't produce anymore
above all thomas droisiker fears a
sudden disruption in supply if vladimir
putin turns off the gas as he has done
elsewhere rationing could follow and his
plastic moldings company would be done
for
as long as that doesn't happen he can
take the pain of rising energy prices
we were founded in 1929 which was the
biggest economic crisis
and we survived world war ii
and some other crises in in the last
decades
and i think there will be a life after
after putin or after this crisis
100
his employees can't afford to be as
confident
just uh
with what is going on prices of course
of living is getting getting higher not
only energy
food prices oil everything petrol
the situation getting hard
that's what germany's government is
focused on it fears a recession of its
heavy reliance on russian gas is reduced
too quickly
even the climate change envoy agrees
if getting off russian fossil fuels is
so critical why can't germany do it
faster
germany is moving as fast as we possibly
can to get off fossil fuels you're
seeing that in the phase out of coal
you're seeing that with moving forward
on oil and we're moving as fast as we
can on gas but we need to be doing that
in a balanced way that also
makes sure that germany is a stable and
balanced place according to government
critics these issues were largely
avoidable
the problem is that germany is the only
industrialized country in the world that
is simultaneously phasing out nuclear
power and coal power we have simply
narrowed the supply of energy too much
and are now in this situation where we
are dependent
and some are warning that even if europe
could agree on a russian gas embargo it
might not even work
we need to remind ourselves the russian
central bank still has 300 billion in
foreign reserves a lot of that in the
form of gold in the cellar so this can
be spent which means a short-term impact
on the war is relatively unlikely
no good options apparently available as
germany's moral and economic dilemma
continues and the war in ukraine rumbles
on
hannah thomas peter sky news in berlin
and you can watch more of hannah's
interview with germany's climate envoy
jennifer morgan that will be on the show
for you tomorrow
now the world health organization
believes the 2020 coronavirus outbreak
in wuhan china most likely started after
the virus was transmitted from bats to
humans via another species well now in a
new report scientists forecast that by
2070 thousands of viruses are likely to
be transmitted between different species
that is largely as a result of a warming
planet well our science correspondent
thomas moore joins us now uh hello there
thomas does this mean that we're going
to be looking at more pandemics coming
our way
well certainly not long ago a new
pandemic virus spreading from wild
animals to humans would have been seen
as the stuff of hollywood but cobit has
shown us the threat is very real and it
could happen again
this research suggests there's likely to
be at least 15 000 instances of viruses
spreading between species by the year
2070 driven by climate change and
according to the study published in the
journal nature even just two degrees of
warming
survival for some species will mean
moving hundreds of kilometers to cooler
or more stable environments and that
will bring them up close with animals
they've never been in contact with
before a perfect scenario for
transmission of viruses from one to the
other and of course with agriculture
expanding and urban areas too people are
coming into closer contact with wild
animals raising the risk of what
scientists called zoonotic spillover
that's when these viruses spread into
the human population now there's thought
to be 10 000 viruses circulating in wild
animals
that are largely unseen but could
infect humans so what to do well the
researchers say there's two things one
is to
carefully monitor the movement of
animals particularly in high-risk
tropical areas of africa and southeast
asia but also they say we need close
surveillance of novel viruses that do
have pandemic potential
all right thomas thank you uh
frightening stuff
well let's uh get caught up on some of
the day's other climate news now and
climate activists damaged petrol pumps
and they stopped motorists from entering
four courts at several motorway service
stations this morning more than 30
supporters of just stop oil took part in
those protests that took place across
surrey and kent the group has been
demonstrating since the 1st of april
they say they will continue the
disruption until the government promises
to stop new oil and gas projects in the
uk
a report by a global forest monitoring
project has found that the world lost an
area of forest the size of the american
state of wyoming in 2021 global forest
watch said that over 97 000 square miles
of forest was destroyed last year with
wildfires in russia and deforestation of
the brazilian amazon causing significant
losses
last year remember at cop 26 in glasgow
more than a hundred world leaders
pledged to halt deforestation by 2030.
now heat wave warnings have been issued
across india as the country swelters
under unusually early and extended
extreme temperatures
well although heat waves are common in
india during the summer the high
temperatures began much earlier than
usual this year with the warmest march
in
122 years the capital new delhi hit 43.5
degrees today can you imagine its
hottest april temperature in more than a
decade the united nations has warned
that heat waves and humidity related
heat stress are likely to intensify
across south asia if more isn't done to
tackle climate change
well joining me now to discuss this is
dr r peter mondal an associate professor
at the department of civil engineering
and climate studies at the indian
institute of technology in mumbai uh
hello there to you
professor it's hard enough isn't it uh
to cope with extreme temperatures like
this if you have access to air
conditioning and running water but many
of the people affected in india won't
have either of those
you're very right and you know our
nation is in a developing state the
nation is being built there's a lot of
construction happening and those
constructions rely on daily wage workers
who if they don't show up at work at the
end of the day they're not going to eat
anything so they don't really have a
choice to stay indoors
and unfortunately these are the
communities who are really vulnerable to
the deadly effects of the heat wave
along with of course the elderly
population children
and you know people with uh
co-morbidities
so you are very right
most of india do not have access to air
conditioning or
in fact there is not much public
awareness on uh you know how to tackle
with these heat waves you know how much
should you hydrate how many hours should
you stay outdoors
we have a lot to do in building public
awareness in that regard
now these heat waves are coming earlier
they're more widespread it's a
confluence of factors isn't it that has
brought these earlier heat waves what
are they
um i think the the single most important
factor is of course anthropogenic
greenhouse gases and aerosol-induced
climate change we have the distribution
of temperatures shifting and when you
have the distributions of temperature
shifting there is higher and higher
chances of having extremes such as these
on in that background climate change
there are also meteorological and
synoptic scale factors uh there are
conditions in the pacific ocean and the
atlantic ocean which can also influence
indian heatwave conditions lack of
pre-monsoon showers because of lower
rainfall from the western disturbances
and generally water what are called
anti-cyclones which is basically a large
area of high pressure sitting on the
land
leading to subsidence so there's no
movement of air and
there is also a feedback from the dry
soils because of low pre-monsoon
rainfall so all of these factors are
playing
a role however we can say with the
scientific community has overwhelming
evidence to conclude that climate change
plays a role in making these events more
intense more frequent and also of longer
durations
dr mandel really good to talk to you
thank you
pleasure
do stay with us coming up i'll be joined
by honorary fellow at oxford's
environmental change institute dr cece
hugh and richard black who is founder of
the energy and climate intelligence unit
we're going to be discussing germany's
reliance on russian fossil fuels and
whether global health systems are ready
for a warming world
[Music]
i was sitting on a sofa
watching the telly and knitting
and my husband said i think i've got
some good news for you
and he turned his laptop around and
showed me a picture of a lottery ticket
and i said oh well if you're saying it's
good news it must be more than 2.50
and he said uh yeah a bit i said so so
what is it and he said no we've won i
said no
what have we won i don't know so he told
me and i just i think for the first time
in my life i was dumbfounded i was
shocked and i had nothing to say so we
stared at each other for about five
minutes
stood up gave each other a hug and i
said i'll go and put the kettle on
chella we've never we've uh we've never
worked so hard either um we uh
my daughter every time i complain that
i'm i'm tired or i'm fed up where i'm
you know she said talk to the hand you
could be lying on the beach somewhere
doing nothing doesn't want to hear so
she makes a joke of it
um
to be fair i'm kind of surprised because
i i just assumed everybody would do that
i patrick said to me um
he always said if when we if we won the
lottery
he would never let me uh open a an email
or answer a phone again because i'd just
give it all away it's just it's just in
my nature i think
and i
he turned around at night and he said to
me he said right that's too much money
but a lot of money you can make your
list now and he gave me a pen a piece of
paper and told me to make my list
my sister was just about to lose her
house
and
save that my nephew was able to buy my
mother's house that we all grew up in
and he lives in that now which was
lovely that's that's family stories
friends
i mean we had one friend we we took them
out for dinner and it was had a little
private dining room and he got up and he
ran around the table
whipping and
throwing his uh napkin around his head
uh we had another friend who just put
his head in his hands and
cried when we told him um
the family and friends thing was amazing
i mean i've been in tears so many times
uh
the
the other gifts and bits and pieces i i
set up the kathleen graham trust in
northern ireland after my mother and i
set up the pfc trust in hartlepool which
is patrick and francis conley and that
was to help me
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news we're getting
straight to discussing the climate
issues of the day with honorary fellow
at oxford's environmental change
institute dr cece hugh and richard black
who is founder of the energy and climate
intelligence unit uh really good to see
both of you now after russia cut off gas
supplies to poland and bulgaria this
week there are big questions for germany
europe's industrial powerhouse and
hugely reliant on fossil fuel imports
from russia well chancellor olaf schultz
on a visit to japan defended the ongoing
trade richard let me come to you
first because the chancellor also uh put
some detail around the plan to reduce
the reliance on russian fossil fuels
didn't he what did you make of what he
had to say
well it's clearly something that's in an
evolutionary state so obviously they've
been talking about this since the
beginning of the war and they've been
looking for various things that they can
do and really it's a bit of everything
so it's energy efficiency and it's
turning down the thermostat and it's
building out renewables faster than
trying to get supplies of gas from other
countries more coal is going to be burnt
i think certainly if it's early um next
winter so it's a bit of all of it but
one of the things that's often missing
from this discussion though is that um
the energy sector is actually private
sector operated and so we tend to think
in terms of governments talking to other
governments and thinking about what can
they do but of course all around germany
the individual companies that whether
they're refineries whether they're
people that you know sell sell petrol
whether they're the the utilities that
burn gas they'll be making trying to
make see what they can do as well and as
this all unfolds i think the picture is
going to become clearer you know over
the next few months yeah you make a very
good point there and it does often get
overlooked doesn't it
so you see the higher price that we've
seen
over the last few weeks of gas and oil
means that a case can be made for
renewables that isn't just about climate
goals
yeah exactly so i think the ukraine
crisis really has highlighted the fact
that you know rely on a single supply of
fossil gas isn't the best way to go and
there is a huge need for diversification
it is fortunate like that we you know
live in a world where there are
alternatives to fossil fuels so the
higher energy prices as you correctly
pointed out can make investment in
renewable energy um more attractive and
profitable and therefore giving us a
opportunity really to act now and
undergo a rapid transition a clean
energy transition which is required um
for mitigating climate risks
richard factory owners who were speaking
to our climate change correspondent said
that they would happily take the
financial pain
to move their business away from russia
because of the principle of it but they
can't do that indefinitely can they
no they can't do it indefinitely and of
course they've got their workforces to
to to to think about as well i mean many
of whom don't support many of whom don't
support what they're doing
well it would be a test wouldn't it of
how solid that support actually was um i
mean you know
germany there's a lot of talk obviously
about what would happen if russia did
turn off the tax i think currently it
looks unlikely that it will and that's
the government's belief as well partly
because german firms seem to be prepared
to make payments um on the conditions
that russia has specified whereas that
wasn't the case with poland and bulgaria
but it is a possibility um that it would
happen and um it would certainly be very
interesting it would definitely spur the
movement to renewables and the increase
in energy efficiency and i think much
more and of course when companies are in
that situation they then have to um they
have to adapt but i think what cc was
saying earlier i completely agree with
that there were already so many reasons
for moving to renewables and increasing
energy efficiency
it's cheaper you don't have climate
change you reduce air pollution and you
increase the jobs well this what this is
really showing is if you want to
security of supply if you really want to
be able to guarantee energy to your
citizens and you want to be able to
enact a foreign policy that is free of
blackmail from other countries over
energy you have to go down and clean
energy routes yeah cc i mean we've been
talking about renewables but
what about nuclear and will the
countries who typically shied away from
it have to look again
yeah i think i would like to come back
to the point about the need for
diversification and the need for the
transition to you know um
renewable energy because you can't just
rely on a single source um nuclear is
part of the picture but they
we should have a very good mix of energy
sources so that this kind of stuff
doesn't happen again
richard
is germany ever likely to change its
view on nuclear power i mean the the
greens oppose it and they're now part of
the ruling coalition
yes i think the thing is with germany it
spent a long time as the frontline state
in a possible nuclear conflict germany
was of course two countries until
1989 and east germany and the soviet
bloc west germany in the nato block and
nuclear missiles on the soils of both
countries pointed at each other that's
left quite a legacy on the national
psyche in the west they also felt very
personally i think the lying about the
chernobyl disaster that came from the
soviet union so because all of that
there is definitely you know a powerful
public opinion against nuclear but the
other thing about nuclear is it takes a
long time to build the government did
look at keeping open the three remaining
nuclear power stations that are supposed
to close at the end of the year and
there were various problems over safety
inspections fuel availability employees
that kind of thing they probably could
have done it if with enough effort but
if you're talking about restarting
building new nuclear reactors you're not
going to see the first electrons flying
out of that probably for a decade so it
definitely can't solve the crisis that
we have now yeah our countries need to
think about their short term and their
longer term planning don't they
let's take another look at the other
story that we were featuring this
evening we were hearing earlier that a
warming world will lead to a huge
increase in the transmission of viruses
from animals to humans it's really quite
a terrifying thought isn't it uh
cece in case we wanted any more
depressing
news um what is the link between climate
change and viruses
so um we know that global temperatures
are rising um that's a fact when
temperatures rise animals and plants
will have to adjust their behavior and
movements to survive and because they
carry diseases um you know therefore
there is an increased risk of them
moving around and you know giving the
diseases to us humans
i think the fundamental question here is
whether our global healthcare system is
resilient enough um is it strong enough
to take another pandemic for example or
is it you know strong enough to take
even smaller outbreaks of diseases um in
the uk 30 percent um 37 of our
healthcare workers are severely burnt
out right now and you know thousands of
them
yes it's it's really quite quite bad um
and thousands of them are you know
thinking of leaving the nhs and actually
you know more than four in 10 gps who
quit the nhs quit because of burnout so
i'm really concerned that climate change
will put more pressure on already very
vulnerable system and this is you know a
developed country right and um because
it's gone through covet and what happens
you know to the global healthcare system
um especially the ones in developing
countries who are going through this and
going through more disease and outbreaks
it's very concerning
richard if we see how one virus brought
health systems around the world to its
needs the percentage of gdp that
countries spend on health we're going to
have to radically up that aren't we
yes i think we are i think we're also
going to have to get much better at
cooperating with each other because in
the covid pandemic governments really
did go it alone we saw vaccine
nationalism and hoarding of vaccines and
things like this and basically a
reluctance to commit to the who's kovacs
fund for example
and that's not going to work if we're
going to have more and more pandemics uh
coming along i thought i thought this
was a really interesting study by the
way this is something i had not really
thought of but it does put together two
well-known facts in science one is that
you know diseases do jump from animals
to humans and there's nothing new about
that go back to the days of the plague
that was happening um but of course you
know we also know that climate change is
driving migration
of species it's well documented by you
know ipcc reports um and you do have you
know
animals groups of animals that have
existed together you know perhaps in a
predator-prey relationship or something
like this one of them may migrate faster
than the other one so what happens uh
what happens to that ecosystem can it
survive um but
this this this this point about diseases
is is newly made and of course
potentially they could jump from animals
straight to humans but potentially they
could jump from one species to another
one and that's to humans so lots and
lots of unknowns in this one
yeah pretty depressing stuff isn't it
well that's all we've got time for dr
cece who and richard black thank you
very much for your time on sky news's
daily climate show
now on the show tomorrow we're going to
be joined by the director of policy and
translation at the grantham institute
alyssa gilbert and james streeter who is
chair of the interclimate network
but do stay with us here on sky news
because coming up beth rigby interviews
tonight fiona hill former senior
director for european and russian
affairs on the u.s national security
council she's also going to be talking
to the former first lady of south africa
gracia michelle and the ofsted chief
inspector amanda spearman for now thank
you for watching and hope to see you
next time
[Music]
you